no he was on top naked he put his
clothes on when I ran up and started
walking down the hill okay so we went
from the Hollywood Hills by the time the
cops came I'm on my phone I called the
cops they said you're not allowed to
follow him because if you do uh he can
press charges on you get stuff
don't tell him that how about that
[Music]
Nick what do you think about people that
steal catalytic converters
um I think you know they're just
speaking to the mic they're just down
bad you know they just need the money oh
okay yeah it sucks it's really
inconvenient but I just think um they're
just down bad do you think they deserve
to die for what they're doing no no I
feel like you've said that they deserve
to die before no I haven't not for
Cadillac converters because I could very
see very easily see myself doing that
stealing it yeah dude
see yourself saying that they should die
no no no yeah actually yeah that too
that's you but I just say anything on
here dude
depends on my mood sometimes yeah it
depends on the day I might be a little
angry or something well something uh
something can I say something please
real quick if I got my catalytic
converter stolen
the next day I'd be like dude everyone
that steals it should be [__] dead
that's why I would say that yeah I can
see that once it happens to you yeah
yeah so um
a lot of people outside of California or
may not understand the importance of
like
um we got this thing called the
catalytic converter it goes on your car
it converts the excess pollution coming
out of your tailpipe so that it's you're
not polluting as bad but uh every car
like requires it and
um when it gets stolen it could cost
anywhere from like a thousand to like 3
000 to get a new one sometimes and it
makes your car so loud yeah it's a very
inconvenient thing to have to fix but by
law you just have to have it so it's
kind of like that thing that gets stolen
a ton because it's stolen for a lot of
reasons first of all there's elements
inside like a Palladium in it and copper
that people want to resell and you can
make a lot of money doing that and also
some shops steal it so that you gotta go
buy another one and they'll sell you one
stolen from someone else's car so it's
kind of like this weird Cali Loop that
keeps going and there's massive busts
going on where they're finding like
um like catalytic converter Thief gangs
that are just piled up to the thousands
and um and they ship them to other
states that also have the same emissions
laws so it's become this theft ring
thing so a lot of people are sick of it
what happened in Palmdale is that a
catalytic converter Thief was killed
while trying to steal one whoa but not
in the way that you might expect what
happened is he was sawing it off of a
car while a lady was asleep inside of it
oh [__] and then she panicked because
she heard a bunch of stuff going on and
thought maybe she was about to be
carjacked she didn't know or see anybody
doing anything she turned her car on
reversed it and ran the dude over hell
yeah that's fair game I think [__] oh
you're okay with that dude
that's fair game squish his ass
that's crazy he didn't he didn't know
she was in there he didn't know because
she had her thing like she was sleeping
and I guess when you got to do that you
have to do fast right you can't be seen
lurking the whole like area right that's
true that's true you know what blows my
mind is like how can you die over that
when I had my foot ran over by a tire
before I didn't do [__]
um I mean so that guy was a [__] like I
was late you guys never had your foot
ran over by a tire I feel like this
guy's body got ran over though by the
car or maybe his neck got squished by
the time that's why I'm like if my foot
can get ran over how can your body get
ran over but it's so it dies this is the
[__] up part where Ryan's like oh by
the way he was 14 and I was like
trap there's no trap this dude like when
you steal a catalytic converter you have
to get pretty like in there yeah so you
you'll just see legs sticking up pretty
much if someone's doing it there's one
time at at uh one of my Studios a guy
was stealing the Cadillac converter off
a client that was shooting at my studio
so everybody ran downstairs and then um
within minutes he got it off and the
dude was just putting in his truck the
owner of the car was just standing in
front of him going like what the hell
man and the guy just goes bye it just
puts it in and they drive off because
there's nothing you can do they should
have hit him with a car but then they
kind of know that like if you shoot that
dude or do anything you're going to jail
nothing's happening him like it's a
greater charge that you're trying to
attack someone or shoot somebody so is
this lady gonna get charged no because
she didn't know she had no idea she
could actually prove that but but in
California you'd never know dude she
might she might go to jail for this but
it's Palmdale
they operate different out there that's
true though you know they probably lazy
but it is it is uh
free to go just leave it yeah she was
able to uh well at least they believed
her that like oh she just patented
because she heard some noises and got
scared and it's not like there's there
was no time for her to like look out and
see that was happening like you have to
process a lot like if you just wake up
in your car seat that's like the best
excuse man it is
[Laughter]
but if I only work for like an old lady
though you know you look at the old lady
all right I'll believe you it's only
gonna work with some like Mom with no
priors but yeah she hit the reverse and
just jetted back if Johnny looks at me
he's like yo I didn't know
[Laughter]
oh [__] uh I don't know yeah you're
right didn't know it's Paul nail yeah
you're right
thumbnail yeah so that's I think this is
the first of this type of thing to
happen for people that are stealing
catalytics like oh so no one was ever
killed like this was like I think there
are people that have may have been shot
at but um but this has never happened
where a per the owner of a car
accidentally like didn't know and just
like ran them over it seems like there's
a lot of just open theft going on now
like like there's the Smashing grabs
that people been doing like they just
running getting their [__] TJ Maxx
purses and [__] running out or
cheesecake that [__] is wild what is a
resale on that crime by the way the way
people would just be stealing this [__]
nowadays is like it's it's [__]
coordinated calculated quick and don't
give a [__] at the same time you know
what I'm saying like I'll be I'll be
like looking at like I swear every other
week I got somebody's in the IG stories
like yo I got my car broken into lost
all my camera equipment lost all my golf
clubs lost on my whatever the [__] you
know what I mean yeah and then start
like watching all these YouTube videos
because you got to go down this Rabbit
Hole to be like how do I protect myself
and you start seeing how they're doing
it how like these are constantly walking
up and down a block and then like
circling areas and scanning and scoping
and then being able to like they even do
the whole patience game where they'll
break the back window just to look
inside and make sure that they can like
open up the back seats in the trunk even
if you've got trunks clothes they're
more and more bold now too yeah dude on
the on the Ring app and the one thing
you see all the time at least in my
neighborhood is people losing their
[__] dogs constantly and the other
thing is like people just walking around
like somebody just came into my my
neighborhood and just opened my car and
you see people just open car doors they
sit inside and they're just like look at
their [__] and they happen all the time
or they're just always checking car
doors well when you got your scooter
stolen all you could do is this right
you couldn't get nothing from yeah and
[__] cops that came like hella
late and stuff like that the dude didn't
give a [__] that it was stolen it was
just like I got to train this uh new
hire cop so it's just like training them
he doesn't yet know how to not give a
[__] yeah yeah yeah don't care about him
yeah
my body language it's like this
sure
hey uh Johnny honest question honest
question uh when you see things going on
around the world or just in Cali and you
see all these people doing crimes and
they're just it's Catch and Release and
they just get right out are you like man
yeah we got a little Envy bro right
where was y'all when I was you know I
said yeah where was that da when I was
going in dude I would have voted for you
too
that gas going is a good guy the [__]
that people are getting away with now I
could not even think of exactly I
thought I was gonna get locked up for
the smallest things growing up yeah for
sure now it's like you just watch your
[__] get jacked all day you're like all
right the thing I can do about it yeah
like that one remember I was telling you
guys at the time that a dude broke into
the house and was taking a bath and I
had to chase them out yeah was he
wearing a hair like a hair net and the
the [__] scrubbing with a rubber
ducky
and the Airbnb was four floors uh high
so I would stay in the bottom floor
families would come in and they'd stay
over we had this nice like Swedish
family staying over they sent me a
picture they texted to me and they go
who's this man he's up and he's just in
the tub the naked guy in the tub and I'm
like I'll be right up and I run up there
I gotta chase this guy down
um the owner of the home is like I
called him I'm like yeah I'm chasing him
right now the owner's like do not let
him out of your site I want this guy
arrested press charges whatever so I'm
following him down the street this guy's
like kind of like power walking away
from me well did he did he get out and
dry himself or did he walk out like oh
he he had like shorts on so he was in
the tub with shorts on no he was a tub
naked he put his clothes on when I ran
up and started walking down the hill
okay so we went from the Hollywood Hills
by the time the cops came I'm on my
phone I called the cops they said you're
not allowed to follow him because if you
do uh he can press charges on you get
the [__] don't tell him that how about
that
time uh the cops came we were on Melrose
like we were like far as hell yeah and
then the cops came and they were like oh
where is he and I was like well you told
me to stop following him so I don't know
where he is
he's like good yeah they're like we'll
check the area and that was it never
heard from it again he didn't check the
area that is a genius idea though if I
was a bum
I would want to take a bath because I'd
be like man I haven't taken a [__]
nice bath I'll make some nice ass
Bubbles and she'll be like damn this guy
got a rubber ducky this is set and I'll
just be like chilling there
you know that'll be nice and then when
you get caught you're like you can't
follow me I'll press charges that's a
crazy that's a crazy thing is that like
I don't know if he like what he did in
the house I don't know if he like if he
took anything I don't know if he broke
anything I don't know I just don't
understand the logic behind that rule
like how does that work all of these
Captain release laws but like that
specifically like I break I'm breaking
into your house I'm [__] messing with
your [__] and then you can't follow me
or I can sue you or press charges I can
arrest you bro like what does that even
mean yeah man because once he's no
longer a threat and he's out of your
property then now you're stalking him
that's that's the key they're like
you're not in your house no more that is
dumb it is [__] dumb that's why low
key when I read articles like this and
I'm like oh man she killed a Cadillac
converter thief and got away with it
it's like the universe is telling you
there is a way you just gotta be crafty
if someone breaks into your house you
beat the [__] out of them and then you
super glue their hair to a catalytic
converter yeah and then you run them
overcome steal my [__]
I was asleep I Sleepwalk look at his
hands [__] super glue to my [__] I
don't know why he was super good I don't
even know why he beat himself up Kobe
has no equipment to steal it with he's
just touching it
because you put a hamburger you know
I've heard about this before I heard
about this in Palmdale
did you hear about that case